why is millennial humor so weird
get these memes joke's on you dad you
don't understand this joke well I
understand every single level of meme
intricacy of this you think you're so
smart huh
it's this laws oh you don't understand
don't you oh you can't be part of my
little secret joke club now yeah I watch
Marble MRB II I hit three jobs every day
son
why is millennial humor so weird just
don't get it what's funny about a
cartoon you have been visited by a dog
so what where's the punchline
how am I supposed to how if I don't know
what the jokey why is millennial humor
so weird what am I even looking at why
does it look so weird
why's markiplier space photoshopped on
top of we eSport I don't get it why is
millennial humor so weird may review
everybody YouTube's favorite show where
I explain the joke
therefore ruining the joke there for
killing the meme I'm your host waters
may have seen that Lord Farquaad with
markup on here photoshopped on top of it
saying II now the joke here it is so
funny just wait until I explain it but
first let's review the meet for some
reason it's just a meme to photoshop
marks face on top of the head with lord
farquaad's base body it looks good like
I'm strangely around not around that's a
bit far could it be the perfect match of
the squared faces that they both have
I'm not gonna call mark short because
I'm people call me short when it's not
true you know there's a discrimination
in the short community but here's a
little of less than average height let's
just say that literally you need to be
an intellectual to understand this mean
now of course they're more than
indistinguishable this name is the
better it gets
just wait until you hear the joke guys
it's gonna be great this meme has now
become oh the joy of the Millennial
humor is so weird before he used to be
like so straightforward memes then
moving Jamaica am i a pirate of the
Caribbean memes now it started from
Photoshop from cyndago it makes me so
uncomfortable these look nineteen fifty
in the future I bet literature and
culture I can't read
I forgot my contact lenses don't make
fun of my glasses guys okay I don't like
wearing them
I bet literature and culture will have
advanced to be greater than ever before
2018 Hey I'd be seeing a lot of these
popping up and left and right
opens a package and sets the Box aside
my cat it's free real estate hahaha I
understand because I know the quote this
is another perfect example how memes are
just hieroglyphic no one's gonna know
what the f this means one day yes that's
right it's not like communications and
the way we store it information in
general has improved instead of beyond
writing things on walls
we're so quirky am i right I hate this
this tumblr each type of humor of like
we're so random right now guys you're
ruining this meet
[Music]
why is it funny I don't know II of
course of course
how can I've been so blind let's just
cut to the punchline
[Music]
to eat or not to eat that is the
question
wall e MC square of course equals e
that's right Oh Bo I can barely see this
one that means it's extra funny did it
did it touch did it data II D versus be
the ultimate battle which mean will win
which we will conquer hmm this mean gets
of cords and rate I would rate this an
eight cuz it's pretty funny it makes me
laugh but the tumbler is group of haha
we're so perky look no one gets this
ruins it so I'm gonna have to give it a
- I'm sorry mark
my ass spicy chicken curry this doesn't
work you need coca-cola light everyone
is keep posting this mean and Mia and
intellectual clearly it doesn't work you
need to use coca-cola light you can't
use regular a coke
it might work a little bit but not as
effective and if you want the mean to
work at least be factually correct with
your meat please this is the meme
correction I do it again and do it right
mom says - my seat though
so this meseta meme has been going on
for a long time I know everyone's gonna
be like everyone that writes mean
comments about me with you I I have your
data I will find you and I will
physically harm you now I know what
you're all thinking why has there not
been a despot c22 yet huh why what is
taking so long
Donald Trump tweeted esposito - coming
this fall
hooray suicide rate dropped 10 to 0
Wow dear liberals disperse Ito Navarino
why is millennial humor so weird
I don't get it it's so crazy disperse
e23 found on Mars heck yes so just
procedure 3 confirmed as well but where
is this resi toe - dear liberals this
precedes the ultimate argument winner
it's taken over from no you just just
hit him with a deaf besito it works
every time
for tonight collabs with this procedure
yes oh my favorite things are
collaborating I love that are there's
love and positivity getting spread
across the world
Eminem dee confirms this besito 47
[Music]
Eminem more like a mean lamb
[Music]
god I hate this procedure - will be
delayed damnit Eel Marsh Byers and then
deletes this receiver
darlin releases destro 0:17 desk besito
- confirmed by NASA
yes procedure seven announced at e3
Nolan will direct that potato for that
spring oh my god that would be so cool
like a really neat gritty and dark
that's fuzzy dough can you imagine that
for now I would say this is sort of a
prequel mean it's sort of a can we get
orange boy into fortnight type of mean
but the mean will I think when it
thrives is it's desperately to to
actually comes out it wouldn't surprise
me at least a point it's the most viewed
song on youtube of all time if they make
a desperate seat or two they will make
history
I need a despot seat at you I don't
think I can live any longer without a
desk or C go to this mean gets a ten out
of ten because I need this but C to so
badly is there any way I can inject
disperse Ito in my bloodstream in my
veins in my skeleton in my DNA let me
know hook me up in the comics I know the
power of patriarchy I know what men can
do when they're angry bonus meme this
week finally I'm shaking I'm shaking
that instead of saying no we can now
instead just say yes and that's right if
you're an absolute Batum a SOI boy that
can't face with any type of
confrontation instead of saying no you
can now just say yes and yes and yes and
I don't don't you want to do something
no and spare yourself something na or
nahan or no your own open or anti yes
opposite yes
just say yes and there's of course other
ways to use this same principle in your
everyday life instead of playing
commonism just say food and nurse er
you've been in a coma since 2017 do
people still use it mean for
nurse yes and if no can be yes and and
yes can be not then Jess can be yes in
didn't and no can be known and two men
men this is a sexorcism okay
why can't there be woman and woman Inge
huh yes yeah yeah nah yeah nuns
everybody nun change all stop signs -
gone signs come on guys if we can get a
hundred times this will actually happen
let's do it together
for the epic means guys as a community
yeah we're so quirky cross cross salute
so lame dog Oh hmm dead live from this
meme gets a zero everybody see what I
did there absolutely hilarious make sure
it smash that like button
can we hit it 50,000
main review everybody YouTube favorite
chef
I'm your host
Jack septic Anand